more cleverly yeah brother pretty cool
you know great guy you know I'm
down-to-earth guy tremendous football
player you know we always see we can't
wake up and I can't wait to see them
again
you see some of yourself in him that's
Mark Jackson one of the MVP candidates
who is having a special second season by
far the best of the 2018 quarterback
draft class and it's our Thursday
matchup draft as we prepare you for week
11 Chris has the trivia question that
will determine who gets the first pick
Chris lay it on me the last six Browns
head coaches have been fired after a
Steelers game can you name three of them
Rob Kazinsky Hugh Jackson and Pat
Shermer I mean could you guys give an
easier one I mean like seriously I mean
you guys are gonna ask me next week like
what's the square root of 7042 and you
just give him
let's pick three of their name three
head coach they've all been fired within
like the last six years I mean holy crap
that was just a bullcrap question stats
I don't know what else to say go ahead
you jerk wait a minute I didn't do
anything I just got the that was so easy
that was ridiculous name name the last
six head coaches for the Browns I mean
yeah okay they've all been fired it's
all been within the last you know okay
okay wait a minute wait a minute I'll
give you the first pick if you name the
other three I got Jackson it's not like
you still came you can't prove to me
that you can read it I I it's question
of all all right yeah there's a pic I'm
going to start with deshaun Watson and
Lamar Jackson without question we are
searching for the next Tom Brady and
Peyton Manning and we've had this
round-robin so far this year Lamar
Jackson saw Patrick mahomes back in week
3 mahomes in the Chiefs won then Pat
mahomes saw deshaun Watson later in the
season and deshaun Watson and the Texans
beat the Chiefs now the circle has come
Lamar Jackson and deshaun Watson and you
know to make it all fit just right
Jackson wins
so everybody's 1 in 1 in this three-man
rotation as we hope for that next annual
rivalry that results in playoff games
between these two quarterbacks but
Watson and Jackson for the first time
ever getting together one of the best
games of the weekend and I think that's
a critical matchup even though they're
not on the field at the same time but
how these guys through when they're on
the field is critical you're the MVP
race Chris exactly I mean this is why
I'm mad I this is my pick I wanted this
damn pick I mean gosh but you're right I
don't care that they're not on the same
field because I do think this is one of
these games where it's going to come
down to which quarterback makes plays
you know the Houston Texans they're
there they like to run the ball I don't
know if they're gonna be able to run
against the Baltimore Ravens front you
know we know the Ravens secondary is
very good so they're gonna cover up some
of the things the Houston Texans want to
do but there's not great speed on the
edge of that Ravens defense so you know
deshaun Watson is gonna be able to
extend plays and buy time and then I
also to the flip side they're you know
the Texans can stop the run that's the
best are there there are their defense
so it is gonna come down again i think
to lamar jackson extending plays and
making some plays with his arm and do
things like that so yes that was the
first pick good job by you you're
exactly right I don't care if they're
not on the same on the field at the same
time either Doug Peterson verse Bill
Belichick that will be my first pick I
just look at that and I think that's a
great matchup of course the Super Bowl
rematch but it's it's fascinating to me
and we hit on a little earlier you know
the Patriots defense is built a little
different than most years they don't
have as many big people as they used to
they have a ton of linebackers and their
versatility and they do a lot of
different things up front or really the
greatness of their defense let alone
they have a lot of secondary guys but
don't have great size and the Eagles
showed a little bit before the buy and
stuff that they were getting back into
let's downhill run let small people
we're big we got real big overpowering
offensive lineman to where I think maybe
they can mash the Patriots up the middle
a little bit just like we saw the Ravens
do so it
that to me is going to be one of the key
matchups of the game and then of course
will Doug Peterson have some of the
Carson Wentz design runs and things like
that off of it that you mentioned in the
first hour I'm very interested to see
what both teams have both coming off a
bye week the wrinkles they have on each
side of those ball Eagles offense
Patriots defense in the matchup and
that's the key from my perspective the
idea that the Patriots have had two
weeks to get ready for it but so have
the Eagles and it does go back to Super
Bowl 52 and I like that matchup it was
on my list but also on my list is
another matchup that has some Super Bowl
52 flashback and that would be the
Jaguars and the cults that would be Nick
Foles getting together with Frank Reich
the offensive coordinator for the Eagles
in that game and this is the first time
they're squaring off because when the
Colts and the Eagles played last year
Carson Wentz was back for Philadelphia
he was the first game that he started in
2018 so Foles didn't get to face Frank
Reich then he gets a chance to face
Frank Frank now and and it'll just be
interesting to see what kind of and
you've got John D Filippo you throw him
into the mix to D flipo was the
quarterbacks coach when Reich was the
offensive coordinator Falls was the
quarterback for that Super Bowl win I
just think that's a great subplot for a
game that is critical for both of these
teams
if the Jaguars want to get back into it
they need to avoid falling to four and
six and the Colts need to reverse this
losing streak they were at five and two
not that long ago now they're staring
five and five right in the face and if
foals can play like he did during that
playoff run last year in the year before
the Colts are gonna be five and five by
the time this one's over yeah I mean
this is a huge game and you know again
yeah I can't get a feel for the Colts
now hey obviously they missed jacobi
percent III could I can sit here and you
know of course I don't know this but if
Jacobi percent plays the last two weeks
I they're gonna win the both of those
games I think they're gonna beat the
Steelers and I think they're gonna
they're gonna beat the Miami Dolphins
but you know that wasn't the case so
this is a huge game in that division and
I you know we both agree that the
Jaguars are a dangerous team they still
have a very good defense and Nick Foles
I think will give a jolt to that offense
for sure I don't know how to phrase this
one I guess I just want to go I want to
almost say Baker and
Nick Shaw verse blitzberg okay because
those are the two guys I almost want to
say Baker and Nick Chubb burst
themselves to a degree and I mean what
I'm really trying to say here is
turnovers are key
if the Cleveland Browns want to win this
game tonight you know I think their
defense can slow down the Pittsburgh
offense I do so the big one of the big
key matchups is can Cleveland take care
of the football that will go a long way
if Cleveland wants to win if then give
Maison Rudy off the ball at the 10-yard
line one sir let you know the Pittsburgh
Steelers scored event's a touchdown
they're probably not gonna win they're
not they're not gonna do it those three
or seven points will be the difference
in the game Pittsburgh is gonna play a
close game that's what they do they
don't care they're right at home in a
1310 1714 22:17 type of game that's
that's really how they want it to play
out so you know we've seen in every game
where Cleveland's played a team that's a
little bit better than them or a good
defense they've found ways to screw it
up whether it's the Titans game the
Seahawks game the Patriots game you just
go down the list
when they better play a defense that has
some talent and scares them a little bit
its interceptions and fumbles and that's
that's I think gonna be a big part of
the game tonight on Thursday yeah I
agree with that completely because look
it's it's it's gonna be the Steelers
defense that either makes a stop forces
a turnover or scores points if the steel
is gonna win this game all right I'm
gonna go to a game that you know we we
assume is going to be an easy win for a
team that just had a big win on the road
on Sunday night the Vikings double-digit
favorites against the Broncos on Sunday
but Vic Fangio is the coach of the
Broncos and last year Vic Fangio when he
was with the Bears his defensive
coordinator swept the Vikings bedeviled
Kirk Cousins and I got Fangio versus
Gary Kubiak current broncos coach versus
former Broncos coach Mike Zimmer talked
yesterday about what an impact Gary
Kubiak has had on that team and you know
kind of takes away from Kevin Stefanski
the offensive coordinator but you know
what so what that's that's how it's
played out Kubiak is influence
has made this offense dramatically
better so now it's a very different
offense from what Vic Fangio had to deal
with last year it's the old Broncos
offense up against the new Broncos
defense and and and I can I could see
the Vikings going into their bye week I
it's not gonna be as easy as you think
it is and Fangio's presence is going to
make it a little more difficult remember
Broncos have had two weeks to get ready
for this one as well so they're gonna be
they're gonna be prepared and they're
gonna be focused and we'll see if they
can keep it close and I think that
Fangio Kubiak factor is is going to play
a big role in what happened yeah III
hear you there I think that that was one
I wrote down too I mean it's it's a
little bit personal especially for a guy
like Kerry Kubiak to to a degree there
but but it is it does seem like you know
you get scared of the Vikings yeah well
just be a game they take their foot off
the pedal
I don't think so though I do think your
Vikings team is for real this year Mike
I think they're gonna be ready to go I
think last week is gonna be one of those
games that's gonna propel them to be
like man we got you know the monkey off
our back a little bit Kirk Cousins got
the monkey the prime time monkey off his
back and all those issues to where it
might catapult them to give them more
confidence and it might not be pretty
but I do think they'll win the football
game my last one here is Chiefs weapons
Chiefs weapons verse Chargers defense
you know and you heard me say before in
one of our pods like hey the Chiefs are
built for doubt score people that's what
they got to do and you know when they go
into halftime and it's only 10 nothin or
10 7 sorry you're gonna you're in
trouble Kansas City your defense is not
good and we've seen that the Chargers
have gotten back to the run game a
little bit which is scary but the big
thing I'm hitting on is the Chiefs
offense mahomes Tyree kill Sammy Watkins
Kelsey you know this Chargers defense
let's not forget last year was that a
Saturday night game or a Thursday night
game
they held the Chiefs offense in check in
a lot of ways they match up well Bosa
and Ingram they can rush for and drop
seven and feel good about it
because they know those two freaks on
the outside are gonna get pressure so
you know I know I'm not like I'm just I
think this
a fascinating matchup because the Chiefs
defense is one of the I mean the
Chargers defense is one of the 10 best
in football they're very good and
they're kind of playing really good
football right now and if they're
susceptible to anything as run game but
the Kansas City Chiefs aren't gonna run
the ball so it's gonna be on behoves and
Tyriq Hill and Watkins and Kelsey to
make some big plays down to Mexico City
and I think that's gonna be a big one
it's I mean this is this is a big game
for the Kansas City Chiefs that they
want to win the AFC West hey the last
time we saw these two teams play in
primetime the Chargers had pulled into
position to steal the number1 seed from
the Chiefs and but for that stumble at
home on a Saturday night against the
Ravens yeah Chargers would have been the
number one seed so so look also another
factor in this game that you mentioned
and I thought about working this in the
the Chiefs and charges combined versus
the field yeah cuz last year they had to
cancel the game because of that field
I'm gonna be watching what is it like
what's it what does it look like are
they slipping are they sliding do they
have good footing and also also that
altitude is for real the the Chargers
spending the whole week in Colorado it's
twice as high as the Mile High City when
you're in Mexico City that could be a
factor as well
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports